I think the political leaders have got
to commit themselves to the euro project
if you go back 15 20 years Chancellor
Kohl and Germany and president meet
Holland France really courageously tied
themselves to the euro and said they
were going to do this and they told the
bureaucrats in Brussels to get behind
them and they intended to lead the
parade the current generation of
politicians haven't been willing to do
that haven't been willing to commit
themselves to the euro project and
really say we're going to do this no
matter what they they sort of commit
themselves a little bit so I like to say
I think that President Draghi at the
european central bank has tied himself
to the mast but the politicians in
europe haven't really tied themselves
they're just helping tie the knots of
Draghi to the mast of the good ship euro
and I think if they all would
demonstrate that sort of political
courage it would be a lot easier for the
citizens and frankly investors to get
behind the project
you